S
REFERENDUMS AS A SHAM IT.
MAY BE THE MARINES' SLOGAN BUT
THE U.S. ARMY IS LOOKING FOR A
FEW MORE GOOD MEN AND WOMEN
TONIGHT.
THE ARMY HAS MISSED ITS LATEST
RECRUITING GOAL BY 25% IT'S A
BIG NUMBER AND BIG PROBLEM.
CHIEF NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER GRIFFIN
IS AT THE PENTAGON TONIGHT TO
TELL US WHY.
>> I AM FINALLY MOTIVATED.
>> THE ARMY CAME 15,000 SOLDIERS
MEETING THIS YEAR'S RECRUITING
GOALS DOWN 25% MAKING IT THE
WORST YEAR ON RECORD SINCE THE
START OF THE ALL VOLUNTEER FORCE
50 YEARS AGO.
SETTING OFF ALARM BELLS AT THE
PENTAGON WHICH CAN SEE WHAT AN
UNFIT RUSSIAN MILITARY LOOKS
LIKE ON THE BATTLEFIELD IN
UKRAINE.
>> I'M CONFIDENT EACH OF OUR
SERVICE ALSO CONTINUE TO FIND
WAYS TO CONNECT WITH THE PUBLIC.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THIS ALL
VOLUNTEER FORCE NEEDS VOLUNTEERS
AND ESSENTIAL TO DEFENDING OUR
COUNTRY AND WAY OF LIFE.
>> 77% OF MILITARY AGE AMERICANS
ARE NOT FIT TO SERVE.
OVERWEIGHT, PAST DRUG USE,
CRIMINALS RECORDS AND CAN'T PASS
BASIC PROFICIENCY TEST.
>> LIKE EVERY OTHER EMPLOYER IN
THE COMMITTEE, WE ARE FACING
OBVIOUSLY ALCOHOLLING CONDITIONS
IN TERM OF OUR ABILITY TO
RECRUIT AND ATTRACT TALENT.
>> EXPERTS BLAME A POST COVID
JOB MARKET AND THE MESSY END TO
THE POST 9/11 WARS.
SOME BLAME TOO MUCH EMPHASIS ON
GENDER AND RACIAL DIFFERENCES.
THE SO-CALLED WOKE MILITARY.
>> YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO JOIN
THE MILITARY TO STAND OUT JOIN
TO BLEND IN AND BECOME SOMETHING
BIGGER THAN YOURSELF.
>> VACCINE MANDATES DON'T HELP
WITH THOUSANDS WAITING TO SEE IF
THEY WILL BE FORCED OUT ON
REFUSING THE VACCINES ON
RECRUITING GROUNDS.
>> IT'S A TOUGH RECRUITING
ADVISEMENT.
YOU HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO BE
HEALTHY TO SERVE.
>>THIS IS A VALID MILITARY
REQUIREMENT.
>> TO DEAL WITH THE FITNESS
ISSUE THE ARMY STARTED FUTURE
SOLDIER PREP COURSE IN AUGUST AT
FORT JACKSON, SOUTH CAROLINA.
A 90 DAY PREBASIC TRAINING
COURSE TO OVERCOME ACADEMIC AND
PHYSICAL FITNESS GAPS.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY THE
REAGAN INSTITUTE.
TRUST IN THE MILITARY IS DOWN AT
5 #%.
YOUNGER AMERICANS HAVE LOST
TRUST IN MANY AMERICAN
INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING T